aimée sheet is a powerful warning of the
danger of food allergies I had a
wonderful wonderful life a wonderful
life this is how life used to be an
ambitious TV producer with the world at
her feet then everything changed on a
girls trip to Budapest in 2014 after
just one mouthful of food in a
restaurant a restaurant she clearly
warned about her nut allergy the
restaurant has not only ruined one
beautiful life it's actually taken away
our lives our lives are totally
devastated totally devastated Aimee
spent nearly a year in a coma and now
her brain injury means she's lost her
sight ability to speak and most of her
movement everybody should be trained in
allergy awareness and understand the
true essence of what fatal allergy is
there are many more people like Amy who
take their lives into their own hands
every day simply by eating and that
number is rising in fact there are two
million people in the UK living with a
diagnosed food allergy but it's believed
the figure is far higher than that
it's estimated that 7.1 percent of
breastfed infants have a food allergy
and as many as 1 in 40 children develop
a peanut allergy we don't know why any
of the allergies are increasing food
allergies or asthma or our hay fever it
we've got lots of ideas about this and
one ideas that we've become cleaner and
our immune system isn't getting educated
anymore
food labeling have come under immense
scrutiny during Natasha's inquest the
coroner finding big businesses to be
benefiting from regulations designed for
small sandwich shops this restaurant
specializes in allergies but not all
businesses are taking enough
responsibility
felt a bit you know and be like why am i
doing everything right and they truly
you know you are as a kitchen the
servers and everyone you know the
restaurant where Amy collapsed didn't
have any liability insurance so her care
is now funded by a trust in her name a
trust
now campaigning for reform three
regulations are in effect they work for
the retailer but they don't work from
Cena because they don't fit in to habit
and something has to be done Amy's
family want to see change and to save
other lives from this suffering the
carefree twenty six-year-old now in need
of round-the-clock care
sorry Lockwood Sky News